on parlait hier soir de l'avenir du parc
olympique du stade olympique entre
autres avec le nouveau pdg de la régie
des installations olympiques michel
labrecque ce soir jean-sébastien
cloutier nous emmène au biodôme qui sera
entièrement réaménagé grâce à un don de
45 millions $ de québec pour le 375e
anniversaire de montréal
c'est en 1992 pour les 350 ans de
montréal que l'ancien vélodrome
olympique devenait le biodôme
à l'aube d'un nouvel anniversaire
l'intérieur de l'édifice sera repensé le
biodôme aura un nouveau design fin 2010
est plus d'immersion plus de lumière
plus de points de vue essayer de masquer
les meneurs architecturaux au maximum
pour être capable de sentir qu'on est
dans un habitat pour les dans un
écosystème donc rajouter des végétaux
rajouter là encore des collections
animal aussi un concours international
d'architecturé vient d'être lancé des
travaux au biodôme devrait coûter 20
millions de dollars
quel que soit le projet choisi les
quatre grands écosystèmes resteront mais
seront améliorés dans les rivières des
laurentides concentre mieux les saisons
qu'on ait de la neige
conte et du brouillard on est de la
pluie selon les saisons
le monde polaire on veut vraiment le
revoir pour ouvrir les espaces que les
les oiseaux les manchots et de la
lumière naturelle un des défis sera
d'exploiter la partie haute du biodôme
qui est actuellement inaccessible au
public
moi je trouve c'est vraiment
exceptionnel comme vue et puis le
travail qu'on veut faire interdire non
sans toucher aux écosystèmes
c'est évidemment de mettre cette voûte
l'a vraiment visible pour le légendaire
et venez ici les gens vont pouvoir venir
ici monter jusqu ici trois écosystèmes
en tout ne sera pas refaire la lumière
naturelle entre plus facilement qu'avant
au biodôme
depuis qu'on a commencé le remplacement
de ses fenêtres sur le toit qu'on
appelle lanterneaux les derniers seront
posées l'été prochain il s'agissait de
la seule partie de la structure du
biodôme a changé l'édifice vieillit bien
le béton est sain il est comme à
l'origine
le bad buzz autour du parc olympique
deux autres concours d'architecturé
viennent aussi d'être lancé 19 millions
de dollars serviront à agrandir
l'insectarium avec l'ajout de nouveaux
pavillons ont choisi provoquer de
véritables tête à tête avec les insectes
l'on veut un peu travaillé sur le
sensoriel alors même le tactile comment
vous vous déplacez donc vous étonner un
peu dans la façon de les déplacer dans
le bâtiment finalement six autres
millions de dollars iront à la
construction d'un nouveau pavillon de
verre ici même près de l'entrée
principale du jardin botanique l'édifice
servira à recevoir des événements
majeurs
trois projets donc qui feront de
l'ensemble des attractions autour du
stade olympique une destination encore
plus incontournable souhaite charles
mathieu brunelle fois que les gens quand
ils viennent ici 10 à l'international va
mourir
t'as jamais vu une expérience comme ça
qu'est ce qui ne s'est pas fait et que
besoins des faits parce qu'un legs doit
être déterminée une présentation
publique des projets finalistes aura
lieu en juillet le jury annoncera ses
trois choix plus tard dans l'année
ici jean sébastien multi radio canada
m'ont rien